Jerome Bettis my buddy Pro Football Hall
of Famer in his Super Bowl champion when
the all-time great Pittsburgh Steelers
back here on the show how are you JB I
am great man thanks for having me on the
show of course absolutely did you were
you watching the Thursday night game
when Adrian did I saw I saw when he when
he went past us uh and you know what he
was he's all he's been an amazing
running back for years so it was just a
matter of time he's been a special
player for a long time and just great to
see him extend his career because you
know obviously beginning here he wasn't
getting the opportunities and he's
gotten them and he's made the best oh
what what does it mean when you hit the
three oh and we're hearing everything
about hitting 30 what what did that mean
to you were hearing all that when you
were going through that in your career
oh you know what for me didn't is
anything because I knew I had a lot left
in me and I think what people need to
look at when they look at running back
it shouldn't be the age it's the carries
I think when you look at most of the
great running backs out of 20 this game
they've been a 3,000 carry kind of
running back the the running backs
that's been really good
they've been 2,000 2,000 carry running
backs and the guys that have been solid
they've been a thousand 1,500 carry and
you go through the history books and
it'll show those carries determine how
long I got play not really the age yeah
I'm looking right here right now and
3468 carries as we're sitting here right
now for one Frank Gore who's sitting
fourth on the all-time list is he
hall-of-famer to you Jerome Bettis no
question no question about it I think
people like to say well he you know he
didn't do anything special but as a
running back your job is to you know get
yards make things happen and he's been
that through the course of his whole
year yeah he hasn't he hasn't had the
Super Bowl runs and all of those but you
know he has some success when he was in
San Francisco yeah
they had a lot of really good football
teams so I think you got to give him a
lot of credit yeah he also he did having
that one Super Bowl run that they had in
the Super Bowl he had a buck ten and it
score he had a hundred ten yards and a
score and the one and that the the 49ers
came up short I I personally think he's
a he's a surefire hall-of-famer I cannot
believe he's still doing it and
amazingly in the last 12 years he's
still the only thousand yard rush of the
Indianapolis Colts of had it's amazing
Jerome what he's been doing it is
amazing and he's been consistently
getting it done and you got to remember
he's doing it on or to reconstruct ease
o to see what he's been able to
accomplish you've got to give him a lot
of credit has been an Iron Man at that
position alright my god you roam about
us here on the Rich Eisen show what do
you make of the Steelers right now I
mean Mason Rudolph it looks like he's
going to be back under center or in
shotgun on Monday night and if the
Patriots do to the Browns what we all
expect the Steelers could be in second
place by the end of eight weeks what
what to expect of the Steelers from here
on out JV you gotta expect the
development of mr. Rudolph I think that
should be no more priority obviously the
defense's they played lights out last
game so can they continue that and I
just think this is one of those years
where you benefit from learning yes
Mason wood off is your number two guy in
the air parent but you also learn about
your defense they've become much more
aggressive than they had last few years
and I think that's always been the
Achilles heel of this team and so now
you get to playing a lot better I think
it uh it bodes well for the future not
necessarily this year yeah I mean in
terms of the defense Jerome there's been
a little bit more of a take away
mentality they've been taking the ball
away and by they I mean one guy in
particular do you know who I'm talking
about
I'm not I think you could be talking
about one gentleman named Bush well I'm
holding up
a little mini helmet on my set right
here that sometimes when you when when
you need to go and find a
difference-maker
and you need to rely on somebody to lead
not only in the locker room but by
example you do turn to a Michigan man
right your home did I lose you
[Laughter]
but there was a lot of minutia in that
in that leader it's all good man he's
great he's DS terrific and he's a good
player he obviously they traded up to
get him he's an impact player he's been
making tremendous plays so you got to
give a ton of credit in terms of him
coming in learning the system which has
been which is incredibly difficult
system and finding ways to uh
to get the job done well you smart you
went to a great school so let's get to
it shall we get to the main event shall
we get to the main event here we're
dancing around it and and your dancing
shoes aren't very pretty let's get to it
I swore to myself when I wound up
getting a mug from JJ Watt with his face
on it and the final score of Wisconsin
over Michigan and it reads on the mug
this mug contains Rich Eisen steers that
I would not make another wager involving
my my alma mater the rest of this year
but I just I can't stay away from it
especially since I really liked the way
they finished up against Penn State so
I'm willing to put something on the line
between our two alma mater this weekend
between us how about you okay you're
comfortable with that so here's the way
I'm looking at it I'm willing to get
whatever piece of Notre Dame garb that
you want send it to me
and I will wear it for a segment during
my show the first day I get it and I
will take a photograph and use it as my
Twitter avatar for a day all right
in exchange I like that Brockman what do
you think of that idea is that a good
idea is it easier to prove do you think
it's weak I could see you're talking to
somebody over there what do I mean I
would prefer a whole week rather than
just a day it's what for the for the
avatar yes okay okay okay because I know
I know what you're gonna about to ask
so it would be commensurate to come it's
called negotiation Chris the hall of
famer here so I think you should show
some respect I'll just fall input in
okay a week that my fault of that
photograph will be my avatar for a week
a Twitter week
Jerome okay in exchange for I should
Michigan win will send to you a hat that
I've made up and on the Hat it says Rudy
is a fraud hashtag fake Rudy you will
have to work you will have to wear that
hat for at least one solid minute on the
field at Notre Dame and have a
photograph of you taken with touchdown
Jesus in the background okay I'm wearing
a I mean I want to miss a no-name and
saltine piece of material okay now if
you say Michigan is the best that kind
of thing that I have to wear at another
game that's something but don't don't
make me okay okay okay okay how about
this then Barrett and Jerome
we'll read I should have gone to
Michigan okay so let's get this that's
all gone let's get this all straightened
out I will make up a hat that says I
should have gone to Michigan you have to
wear it on the field at Notre Dame are
you planning on being there at any point
the rest of this fall I may not if I
don't I will wear it the first time I
stepped on the field okay and then
there's a photograph you will have to
wear it and I need touchdown Jesus in
the background I got it just to just to
confirm it's not just any old stadium
that looks like your stadium okay
there's no picture in front of touchdown
Jesus
okay wearing and if Notre Dame beats
Michigan what do I have to do now I've
got to put it you're gonna send me a hat
of some sort or what are you gonna send
me yeah we got to come up with a hat
something that says oh my goodness you
could just be in Iran there is no
robbery just say Andy's number one just
say we that's all we need to do for rich
he knows I'll have to wear that on the
show for a segment no no Jerome make
them wear it for the whole show no no
not wearing it for the whole show
segment thank you and acknowledging
acknowledge why you're wearing it okay
and it's going to be on your avatar for
a week yep all right Jerome I'm feeling
good are you like I mean you got to come
to our house and beat us when we just
came off of a very difficult two feet
that might bring the team together even
closer than before
good hear you I know you are and you
should be also a or if there's more
victories you guys are team and what
we're capable of it okay okay alright so
I've got my local hat maker already on
it
we'll have to scrap the Rudy's a fraud
hashtag fake Rudy okay and instead I
should have I should have gone to
Michigan I should have gone to Michigan
I should have gone to Michigan I mean
cuz again Jerome I mean you're you're
you've got Michigan roots you are him
you are a Michigan man right Matt you're
you're you're my one of my favorite
Michigan men Jerome I am a man
absolutely absolutely 100% okay that's
my new vid
edit that out I don't need to have any
context for that any time I play that
ever again I just got you okay so I got
that just removed just that's the way
friends treat each other like to think
you're a better person than that I like
to think that not this one maybe family
mistake not this way all bets are off
this week pal very disappointing very
disappointing all bets are off except
for the one we just made
okay Jerome thank you for calling in
thank you for calling in on how's
everything else everything else expect
another phone call after the game okay
so we're chatting next week
win or lose winner win or lose win or
lose win or lose
Jerome we'll talk next week all right
they carry us up high take care okay
that's Jerome Bettis for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app